croire madame merci d'être avec nous on
vient de dire un certain territoires
d'outre-mer qui connaissent un nouveau
pic épidémique qui n'est pas dupe et
rieuse mans en variant delta mais à la
souche originel ou britanniques ou sud
africaine comment expliquer cette
particularité et la pénétration
quasi-nul du delta a la particularité il
s'explique par le taux faible de
vaccination malheureusement de la
population martiniquaise la
contamination actuellement est une
contamination autochtones donc ça veut
dire que les gens n'étant pas vacillé ce
qu'on t'a mis d'eux mêmes et avec une
contamination par des jeunes individus
et les jeunes individus ne sont pas
vaccinés on a eu un taux de pénétration
de la vaccination plus important chez
des personnes plus âgées est
actuellement toutes les mesures sont
essayés pour augmenter cette vaccination
qui sera le seul moyen de lutter contre
la propagation avec même l'autorisation
donc en ville dans les cabinets ce
pouvoir utiliser du kaiser aussi bien
chez les médecins que les pharmaciens
que les infirmiers pour la politique de
la les verts qui est déployée par la
grèce et par la préfecture mais
actuellement bas les jeunes ont un
sentiment de liberté ont envie de
liberté et la contamination de petits
groupes qui avait supprimé les mesures
barrières qui ne sont pas vaccinés qui
ont envie de se retrouver dans la place
d'aller dans un système plus festif cdh
a malheureusement ce constat ne
contaminent les autres et avec un risque
de tension qui est déjà signalé à
l'hôpital avec une mise en alerte étant
donné que nous sommes sûr il que de deux
possibilités d'évacuation donc nous
faisons très attention pour essayer de
circoncire au maximum d'où les nouvelles
mesures annoncées par monsieur le préfet
de renforcement avec le port du masque
avec les mesures de restriction dans les
lieux publics 1 1 qui sont annoncés
comment expliquez vous ces chiffres
aussi faible de la vaccination en
outre-mer
je pense que premièrement comme on était
très peu impactée par l'aco vide
donc tant mieux pour nous mais la
population n'a pas pris forcément
conscience de la gravité de la coville
et de cette nécessité de se faire
vacciner donc on a eu un impact très
modéré donc le vaccin ben oui oui je
vais penser j'attends voir un peu plus
de recul
les patients sont assez réticents alors
vous avez de population et les gens qui
ont voulu ce pacte il est très vite
qu'ils sont venus en premier et puis
d'autres qui se dit jma on va voir on
est loin on a été assez préservé on y
arrive parce que les mesures de
protection qui avaient été mis aussi
bien par les bateaux de croisière sur
les mesures sanitaires aux frontières
l'avantagé c'est qu'on arrive quand même
à protéger aussi bien par bateau que par
avion ont permis de préserver la
martinique et avec des mesures
d'isolement où la population avait bien
joué le jeu avec des mesures de port de
masques et qui étaient respectés
actuellement la population plus jeune et
c'est elle qui est infecté on le voit
très nettement dans les dents les
statistiques nous sont remontés donne
justement cette fragilité avec ce
sentiment de liberté que vous oubliez
précédemment bah non plus on vit
longtemps vie ne se sont pas fait
vacciner donc bien sûr se contaminent et
vous avez les étudiants qui vont rentrer
qui rendront leurs familles institué
avec un avec toutes ces problématiques
alors justement la période estivale
c'est aussi le moment du retour dans
leur région d'origine pour de nombreux
ultra marins notamment les étudiants
vous venez de citer
comment la population après londres cet
été
sous cloche puisqu'il ya encore des
restrictions en outre-mer mais pour le
moment en restriction sous cloche
puisque le là on n'a pas de mesures
syndicats exceptionnel quand vous prenez
l'avion pour venir au mans martic
actuellement vous devez présenter un
test pcr il voulait pas activé vous
devez avoir une période d'isolement de
sept jours
mais si les voyages avec les mesures
d'exception sont remis un sont remis en
vigueur on va totalement changer la
donne donc actuellement les patients les
pas des passions et à des formations
professionnelles les voyageurs
quand ils arrivent ils doivent avoir une
semaine d'isolement fils sont pas
vaccinés qui n'est pas forcément
toujours très respecté mail actuellement
la problématique de la flambée en
martinique elle n'est pas due aux
voyageurs on a seulement 1% de
contamination qui viennent d d'autre
part qui viennent des voyageurs
la contamination pour 99% est autochtone
cela veut dire que le virus circule en
martinique et que les gens ont levé de
mesures barrières on ne prennent plus
les précautions nécessaires
non effectivement vous l'aviez dian en
ce début d'interview enfin c'est sûr
qu'avec cette entre guillemets
transhumances estivales
il ya ce risque désormais aussi de
contamination aux variants delta très
contagieux mais bien sûr bien sûr avec
toute la fragilité imposée par le
système sanitaire qui est déjà en
fragilité aux entier puisque nous avons
un hôpital sous tension avec beaucoup de
deux soignants un petit peu en burn out
avec beaucoup aussi d'arrêt maladie avec
un personnel soignant en souffrance avec
des soignants libéraux qui ont été sur
le compte est la première heure donc
s'ils sont aussi fatigués qu'ils ont
besoin de vacances et tâchant qu'on ne
pouvait pas voyager comme ça qu'il y
avait les mesures de cinq mêlées on ne
pouvait pas prendre l'avion si on avait
pas motif impérieux de voyager donc avec
cette levée des motifs impérieux il ya
eu un vent de liberté qui a permis aussi
de souffler mais actuellement d'un tout
le monde se pose la question qu'est ce
qu'on va devenir qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire donc notre rôle mois
tant que notre rôle au nom de l'union
régionale des médecins libéraux de
martinique est d'inciter la population
martiniquaise à se faire vacciner
beaucoup plus amplement et je veux dire
toutes les mesures sont en place avec
des centres de vaccination ou un
absolument pas de pénurie avec une
possibilité de se faire vacciner en
ville aussi bien par l'infirmier que par
le médecin que par le pharmacien
justement pour faciliter cette proximité
donc il faut avoir recours à la
vaccination pour avoir une unité
collective pour arriver à freiner cette
diffusion à l'inter en intra martinique
merci beaucoup à nos criquets ayo
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour nous exposer cette situation
en outre-mer et notamment et
particulièrement en martinique